S
HEAVILY INVESTED IN.
AGAIN, THIS IS A CRIME.
AND NO ONE IS SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE HOWEVER
IS.
SHE JOINS US.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS TOO COMING
ON.
SELLING OFF ASSETS TO CHINA TO A
COMPANY THAT HIS SON WAS
INVESTED IN.
WHY IS NO ONE SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS?
>> I'M NOT SURE, TUCKER.
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS.
SO DO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE ONE ROLE MOST IMPORTANT FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IS TO PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY'S NATIONAL SECURITY.
OUR STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVES
ARE JUST THAT.
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY, WHEN IT
COMES TO OIL, THE VERY IMPORTANT
RESOURCE THAT WE HAVE THAT FUELS
OUR ECONOMY, HELPS US DRIVE OUR
CARS, AND PETROLEUM ALSO FEEDS
OVER 6,000 PRODUCTS, THINGS
AMERICANS RELY ON EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
BUT JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN SELLING
OFF A MILLION BARRELS OF OIL
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE'RE DOWN TO 434 MILLION
BARRELS OF OIL.
AMERICA CONSUMES AROUND
19 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL A DAY.
WE CANNOT SUSTAIN THIS.
IT IS PUTTING US IN DANGER.
BY OUR TRACKING HE'S SOLD OVER
7 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL TO
CHINA.
OUR NUMBER ONE THREAT THAT WANTS
TO CONQUER US, WANTS TO BECOME
THE NUMBER ONE SUPERPOWER IN THE
WORLD.
BECAUSE OF THAT, TUCKER, IT'S
IMPERATIVE WHEN REPUBLICANS TAKE
BACK CONGRESS, WE HAVE TO HOLD
JOE BIDEN ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS,
BECAUSE HE PLANS TO SELL MORE
OIL OUT OF STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVES.
I'M STARTING AN ARTICLE OF
IMPEACHMENT ON MONDAY, BECAUSE
OF THIS OUTRAGEOUS MOVE HE
CONTINUES TO MAKE, PUTTING OUR
ENTIRE COUNTRY IN DANGER.
>> Tucker: SO HE'S DOING IT NOW,
WE'RE IN SEPTEMBER, NEXT MONTH
IS OCTOBER, THE MONTH AFTER
THAT, IF I'M FOLLOWING YOU
CORRECTLY, WOULD BE NOVEMBER.
THE FIRST TUESDAY OF WHICH IS
THE PIVOTAL MIDTERM ELECTION.
HE'S DOING IT THIS FOR POLITICAL
REASONS, TO GET GAS PRICES LOW
BEFORE PEOPLE VOTE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OUR STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVES
ARE NOT MEANT TO LOWER GAS
PRICES FOR NOVEMBER ELECTIONS.
THEY'RE MEANT TO BE A NATIONAL
SECURITY EMERGENCY SUPPLY FOR
ALL AMERICANS.
BUT JOE BIDEN IS ABUSING IT.
HE'S PUTTING OUR ENTIRE COUNTRY
IN DANGER.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO HAVE ANY MORE OIL LEFT.
HE'S SELLING IT TO OUR ENEMIES
IN CORN COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
JOE BIDEN HAS TO BE IMPEACHED,
AND WE MUST DO IT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT'S NOT HIS.
I KNOW HE'S LIVED AT PUBLIC
EXPENSE FOR HIS ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE, BUT HE DOESN'T OWN THAT.
IT BELONGS TO THE PUBLIC.
HE CAN'T JUST SELL IT TO CHINA.
IT'S TOO CRAZY TO CONTINUE.
>> THOSE ARE HIS BUSINESS
PARTNERS, FOR SURE.